[Music]
welcome back
so if you're just now joining us we're
talking about the sparse identification
of nonlinear dynamics or
cindy algorithm and this is a part of a
multi-video
series on how to use cindy for
scientific discovery
in a number of fields of interest so the
high level goal of cindy
is to take time series data for some
from some complex system
and extract interpretable generalizable
dynamical systems models
that describe that data and are as
simple as possible
have as few terms in the dynamics as
possible
and this can either be in the term the
form of an ordinary differential
equation or a partial differential
equation
and so we've been talking about kind of
one of the key challenges of cindy
so you know we've already described the
overview of how this goes
where you collect measurement data and
approximate
the time derivatives of that data you
build a library of
candidate terms that could describe
those dynamics
things like you know linear terms
quadratic terms maybe sines and cosines
and then you apply sparse regression to
try to
select the fewest terms in this theta
library that are needed to describe
x dot and those terms are the sparse
entries of the columns of this c matrix
so each column of c the first column
tells which terms are active
in the x dynamics which terms are active
in the y dot dynamics
or the second column and the third
column describes what terms are active
in the z dot dynamics
and so we've been going through these
kind of canonical challenges
because i want to make sure that
everyone who watches this
is kind of armed with the state of the
art for how to build cindy models for
your problem of interest we've talked
about the data
what type of data you need the
coordinates how do you know what
variables are good variables to measure
and today we're going to zoom into this
uh
issue of the library how do you build
that theta matrix
so that you have a good chance of
getting a sparse model that describes
your dynamical system
okay good um so again in this big
picture
here we're going to zoom into this theta
matrix here
how do i build a theta matrix of
candidate terms
that i have some hope of representing
these dynamics
sparsely in okay
so at the end of the day cindy is a
generalized linear regression problem
where we're trying to find a sparse
combination of columns of theta
to describe the time derivative of my
measurement data
and so a lot of effort goes into
building this theta matrix and this is
where
you have a lot of creative freedom to
design
new theta matrices that have properties
that you think your system might exhibit
okay and i'll give you some examples so
i work in fluid mechanics often and in
fluid systems
we know that the navy or stokes
equations are quadratic
they're quadratic they have a quadratic
non-linearity because of the convection
term
and so it's very common for us to get
low dimensional models of fluids that
are of the form linear plus quadratic
so when i model fluid systems i often
start by adding linear and quadratic
terms to my models
sometimes we add higher order terms
cubics cortex
quintix and so on and so forth to model
kind of
low energy fluid phenomena that we have
truncated or are not modeling but we
want to account for them
in the structures that we are modeling
so long story short
polynomials are a good choice of theta
for my fluid systems
in general if you start with a new
system here's what i recommend you try
first try just linear terms compute a
dynamic mode decomposition model
see how accurate it is in reconstructing
x dot
see how accurate it is for you know
forecasting take that model
integrate it into the future and see if
it's you know at all reasonable and
accurate
if it's accurate and it works good you
get to go home early you have a good
model
in terms of linear dynamics if it
doesn't give you a good model fit though
if x dot is not well fit
or your dynamics do not predict well
into the future
try adding quadratic terms if the linear
plus quadratic terms work
good you go home slightly less early and
then if that doesn't work you add cubic
terms and so on and so forth you add
complexity
until something clicks into place and it
works i wouldn't recommend starting with
a fifth order polynomial basis
because that might be too complicated so
i would start small with linear then
linear plus quadratic
and then add and add and add until
until something works now for some
systems
we know that polynomials are not the
right basis to describe the dynamics
you might want trigonometric functions
sines and cosines
uh if i'm dealing with you know a
pendulum or something that i know lives
on a periodic
uh configuration space i know my
variables
are you know two pi periodic i'm going
to put in two pi periodic basis
functions
sometimes you might think of bessel's
functions or ares functions the sky's
the limit to what you can add to this
library
but i would caution you to try different
isolated libraries first before you
combine them
because you're always worried about the
condition number of this matrix if this
matrix becomes ill-conditioned
it's very hard to solve for these sparse
coefficients
accurately especially if you have a
little bit of noise in your data
so we're always trying to kind of battle
not making this library
too large or making the columns too kind
of linearly dependent
so like a lot of times sine of x will
look
a lot like a linear combination of x and
x cubed and x to the fifth
so if you have those polynomials and a
sign in the same library
this might be ill-conditioned okay
something you need to look out for
good okay so that's just very high level
advice
now we're going to start looking at some
ways that you can extend this library to
account for other physical effects
so for example oftentimes my dynamical
system is not
compurely you know purely a function of
the state variable
there might be some external forcing
some control variables some time
dependence
and you can incorporate all of those
into this library by adding columns
so for example in cindy with control
this is a paper by
erica kaiser and us
essentially what you can do is you can
augment your right hand side library to
not just include functions of the state
x but also to include non-linear
functions of a control input u
and cross terms and that can really
really be important if you have a
control system that you can kick the
control
and excite transients and you need to
disambiguate
between the internal dynamics and the
effective actuation and control
and this is very very much related to
this idea of dynamic mode decomposition
with control by josh proctor
so illustrated on this very simple
predator prey system
where you have kind of two species a
predator species and a prey species
and we're going to assume that there is
a natural dynamical system in terms of
x1 and x2 the predator and the prey
that's unforced
but then at some point in time at time
100
we're going to come in essentially we
have some control
over the system let's say we're trapping
hairs
right back in the old appalachian days
they would trap hairs for their pelts
and that would change the whole
dynamical system because humans were
controlling or forcing the system
so let's say that for the first hundred
years i had one control strategy i was
trapping at a certain rate
and these were the observed dynamics but
i knew what that trapping rate was
if i just modeled a system in terms of
the predator and the prey without taking
into account the fact that i
had this control knob i was adjusting
then
after i changed the control policy in
the next hundred years
my regular cindy model would be
completely wrong this yellow curve
but if i added in those columns that
took into account what my control
my external control was doing then my
blue model almost perfectly matches
uh kind of what happens in the future
so this is a way of saying that often
times if you're actively controlling a
system
you have to take that into account in
your cindy library or else you'll get
the wrong dynamics
so my colleague josh proctor thinks
about this a lot in the context of
disease systems
you want to model for a disease system
but you can't afford to stop treating
people and stop
vaccinating and stop deploying bed nets
and other intervention strategies
and so you have to have a modeling
procedure
that allows you to simultaneously
disambiguate the internal dynamics
and the effective control without
turning your control off
so that's what we're doing here and
erica has extended this to a full
modeling framework where you essentially
have your unknown
unknown dynamics but you can also have
controllers entering
you collect data in the same way as
before but now we can kind of kick our
controller and try different control
strategies
and we can get sparse non-linear models
for the
dynamics and the effective control okay
so this is pretty powerful
and it allows you to do things like
develop model predictive controllers
based on those sparse cindy models so
you get accurate and efficient
non-linear models
that you can then use with things like
model based control model predictive
control
reinforcement learning control and so on
uh and erica tried this on a number of
systems chaotic systems like the lorentz
attractor and in comparing with neural
networks
for example what she found was that
these cindy models
actually have a much better prediction
horizon they can predict
farther in the future with more noise
because they've learned the actual true
sparse dynamics of the system they're
more generalizable
than neural networks are which is useful
for control
so it's a long way of saying that you
can build your cindy library
to have more effects you can add the
effective control
if you think that there's some time
variation you can add
time columns and cross terms with time
as well let's say we are trying to model
the climate system
and we want to include as a variable the
amount of co2 emissions
we might also want to include as a
variable you know solar cycles and
things like that
those would be additional external
forcing variables
that might affect the state
in the original paper we actually showed
that like control variables you can also
include parameters bifurcation
parameters or tuning parameters
into the model so you can model
discrete differential equations just as
well as continuous with cindy you just
take
discrete time data and you model the k
plus one
time step as a sparse nonlinear model of
the kth time step
and in this example we took the chaotic
logistic map
with the bifurcation parameter mu and we
measured it at 10 different
values of the mu parameter and by
including that mu
column into the cindy library so now i
can have terms that are not just
x and x squared and x cubed but mu
and mu x and mu squared x and mu x
squared
now we can learn the form of this
logistic map
even from a few noisy measurements and
then from that learned model we can
fill in the bifurcation diagram with no
noise at all parameter values because we
learned
the actual true dynamics and this all
happens in the library you have to know
kind of based on the data i'm measuring
what would i want to put in the library
do i have a parametric dependence
how might it enter my system okay very
important questions to ask
good okay um another big avenue of
research
in in cindy is trying to extend this
framework to handle larger classes of
dynamical systems
so what i showed you before allows you
to identify sparse models
in a fixed basis like polynomials sines
and cosines
bessels functions but what if you have
dynamics like this that are rational
functions so you have some polynomial on
the top
and some polynomial in the denominator
and this is work by neil mangan
when she was a postdoc with nathan and
josh
and essentially this is a very hard
class of systems to model with cindy
because these rational dynamics are not
easily expressible as a sparse
combination
of atoms or basis columns of theta
so here's kind of a toy system we were
thinking about these michaelis-menten
dynamics for chemical kinetics in
biological systems
and the idea is that if you have this
rational function
what we can do is we can multiply both
sides by the denominator
we don't know what it is yet but we
multiply it by some hypothetical
denominator
and we get a system like this and so now
we can take this dynamical system
and write it in the same way as our
original cindy problem we have a library
times a sparse vector equals zero
and now this library has to be larger it
has to include not only terms that
describe
f but it also has to have terms that
describe
f times x dots and so essentially what
that means
is that we build a library that's twice
as large it has all of the library that
theta would normally
have and then that same library times x
dot okay and now we're trying to find
the sparsest
c vector that multiplies theta to equal
zero
turns out this is a horrendous
optimization because the sparses vector
c that equals zero is zero and that's
not a very good model is the zero model
so what we ended up finding out in the
course of this paper
is that you don't just want the sparses
c you want the sparsest
c in the null space of this library
theta so this library has a null space
you want the sparse linear combination
of that null space
that gives you this c vector and it
turns out that there actually are
optimizations out there within the last
10 years to solve for this
it's pretty ill-posed because this null
space
explodes in rank if you add a little
noise to your system
but for noiseless data we can learn
very complicated chemical kinetic models
with rational terms
using this implicit cindy approach okay
very cool idea we learned a ton about
cindy and the optimization in writing
this paper with neil
and recently one of
nathan and my phd students khadir den
kamen
has essentially taken this implicit
cindy modeling procedure
and made it robust so now you're not
finding the sparses vector in a null
space
you're essentially using a much more
robust
algorithm to find these models so if you
take that same kind of michaelis-menten
dynamics here
and you're going to multiply the
denominator over
what cardi realized is that instead of
trying to write the entire implicit
equation
equals zero if you know even
a single term that is definitely in your
dynamics
you can move it over to the right hand
side and now you have a regression
that's not equal to zero
so you don't get into that null space
problem and so essentially what cardi
does
is he sweeps through all of the possible
terms that could be in the model
and he one by one moves them over and
tries that model
and if that doesn't work he moves
another one over and tries that model
and one of them
is going to work and give you an
accurate model that is also sparse
so this solves a lot of problems because
in the original
implicit cindy we had a null space
problem very ill-conditioned
by moving candidate terms over and kind
of locking them
into the model this becomes as robust as
normal cindy this has all the robustness
properties of normal cindy
which are pretty good you can handle
moderate amounts of noise
with the kind of standard cindy
algorithm and by testing all of these
terms you can do this in parallel
and you also get some interesting
consistency checks along the way
so really really cool paper i highly
encourage you to read this
uh khadiran came in has done great work
on on this robust implicit modeling
and has shown that we can model systems
that we never dreamed of modeling before
like this bz chemical reaction
so this is a four this is a coupled
system of four partial differential
equations
non-linear with rational terms this is
about as hairy as it gets in terms of
things we would want to model and with
our original cindy framework we would
have no shot at modeling this
we would need data that's way too clean
way too much of it
handling the rational terms would be a
nightmare
but with cardi's approach essentially of
you know picking
at random one of these terms and moving
it over and then doing the regression
he's able to find this very very rich
rational coupled partial differential
equation so that's super cool
a lot of applications of this and this
is hot off the presses so
you know i'm curious to see what people
use this for
in the future okay great um
so a few other things i want to talk
about in this the cindy
library problem that we're talking about
is the curse of dimensionality
so we know that one of the key strengths
of cindy is that this library
expresses many possible model
structures there are many millions of
possible models with
five or six terms out of this library
that you know could be written down and
the sparse optimization procedure with
high probability
searches through that vast model library
to find the sparsest correct model given
by the coefficients of
c that's great but
there is also another kind of cursive
dimensionality
in how many columns this theta matrix
will have
so for three variables and fifth order
polynomials it's not that bad it's
something like
81 terms but if i had 10 variables
and 10th order polynomials this theta
library would be gigantic it would have
you know hundreds of thousands i haven't
computed but
probably millions of columns and it
would be far too
ill-conditioned to take a pseudo inverse
of to do the sparse optimization on
it just wouldn't work okay and so
there's a fundamental curse of
dimensionality we want
to have this library scale well we want
to
basically have as few columns as
possible but still have the flexibility
of representing a large model space
so these are kind of dueling or
competing objectives
good okay that's uh one motivation
to reduce the size of your state x
okay so if you can find some way of
getting
less degrees of freedom to describe your
system
you probably would want to do that in
this procedure because it's going to
make your theta library
scale better now i've been saying a lot
about the condition number
of this this theta matrix and
technically i don't exactly mean
condition number
there's actually a really interesting
paper uh by joel chop
in i think 2009 it's one of the greed is
good papers
um and way in the kind of end of the
paper
in you know i don't know theorem 9 or 11
somewhere deep down i'll try to put it
in the
in the description there is a theorem
about
when you can expect to get exact
recovery of a sparse model
in a library using the lasso regression
now we're not exactly using lasso but
it's close enough
for our purposes and he introduces
a kind of more powerful or generalized
notion of condition number
called the erc condition and it
essentially is a condition number
on all sparse subspaces in this matrix
and it gives you some conditions for
when you can expect exact recovery based
on kind of a generalized condition
number of theta
turns out it's a pretty hard thing to
compute it's kind of an np hard
quantity to compute but it's good as a
thought experiment of what we care about
in this matrix
we if there is a set of columns that is
the true model
some spar set of columns if there are
other
columns in this matrix that are really
really parallel or almost linearly
dependent on those true model columns
this sparse identification is going to
be very challenging
and so that's a reason to improve the
condition number of this theta
to keep it to being as small as possible
because the more columns you add the
more linearly dependent they are
and also to add more rich transient data
to sample more initial conditions
to improve the chances of these columns
being linearly
independent it's kind of a technical
aside but very important i think about
this all the time
if you're serious about these models
you're going to have to think about it
too
your true model structure the sparse
columns you care about
can't be nearly linearly dependent on
model columns you don't care about
or else you're going to get the
misidentification
good cursive dimensionality so we've
already talked about how
one way to handle this for high
dimensional data is to take the svd the
the principal components of that data to
try to crunch it down to a smaller
feature set
that will keep your theta library
smaller uh
a deep autoencoder network is kind of
like that on steroids where you can
essentially
you know take very high dimensional data
and find as few variables
that you think are dynamic as possible
another approach that i think is really
cool is this paper
that came out i guess a couple of years
ago
by our german colleagues where
essentially what they do is they
generalize the cindy library approach
to now include tensor train formulations
for those right hand side dynamics
so instead of our generalized linear
model x dot equals
theta x times c where theta is just a
set of columns
they essentially can kind of compress
that into a tensorial representation
using these tensor trains
and allow for much much larger kind of
polynomial representations
with still being a very compact model
getting away from some of these
ill-conditioning issues and cursive
dimensionality
i'm not going to go into too many
details there's a lot to unpack here i
highly recommend you read this paper
it's fantastic
and it solves one of the most important
problems of cindy which is the curse of
dimensionality
and they show that with their kind of
tensor trained basis they identify the
correct dynamical system
whereas if you use our simple
generalized linear model sometimes you
incorrectly identify only a portion of
the dynamics so
very important paper it kind of
addresses that cursive dimensionality
and one of the last things i want to
tell you about is another way of kind of
handling that library there's a couple
cool things about the library i want to
tell you about
you can also bake in some prior
knowledge of the physics
into that theta library if i know that i
have a symmetric system
you can build your library elements to
reflect that symmetry whether it's an
odd symmetry or um you know two pi
periodic
symmetry or something like that you can
sometimes bake that into the library
so here i'm going to show you uh some
really cool work by ife guan
who exploited symmetry in this electro
convection problem
and i'll talk more about this in the
sparse fluid modeling
video but essentially he takes time
series data
reduces the dimensionality using a
principal component analysis or this svd
and then he's modeling the amplitudes of
these modes as they evolve in time
so the amplitude of the first mode is a1
the amplitude of the second mode is a2
and so on
and these are kind of the time series of
those amplitudes evolving in time
and what we realized when we looked at
this data is that it has this incredible
symmetry
you can already see that if you kind of
flip or rotate in certain ways nothing
changes about the data
and that symmetry can massively guide
how we build our theta library so
we can do this kind of constrain cindy
i'll tell you about the constraints
india in the next lecture
to get this sparse model but we
essentially constrain ourselves to have
a smaller
library and i'll show you what that
looks like here
so by taking the data and identifying
that there are some symmetries in this
case we have five key symmetries
you can determine right off the bat that
there are
many many terms in your theta library
that can't possibly
exist and exhibit those symmetries so
right off the bat
all of these black terms are ones that
we've completely crossed
out as inadmissible with these observed
symmetries
and so right away what that does is it
reduces our theta library
pretty dramatically i mean this is less
than half as big
as it would have been and it allows us
to identify
better models with less data because
there's less variables we're fitting we
have a smaller theta matrix
with a better condition number and we
can identify it with less
data because we've enforced the symmetry
okay so this is just one of the many
things you can do in the theta library
that's one of my favorite parts of cindy
is just the flexibility and the freedom
of designing the library of candidate
terms enforcing symmetries and physics
and really kind of building in your
expert intuition
for the the dynamical systems you're
trying to discover
okay good uh so we've been talking about
these key challenges
we are almost done in the next lecture
we're going to talk about the challenge
of optimization
which is kind of a fun one because there
is so much happening
in this world of optimization like this
is the the lifeblood of
machine learning well maybe data is the
lifeblood this is the engine
uh you know that's kind of making
machine learning work is all of these
optimization algorithms so that's coming
up next
all right thank you